Salut Clément, ça va ?
On se fait la bise ?
C'est une blague En***é.
Tu sais où on peut attraper des "Carapuceau", des "Leviator" et des "Magicarpe" en masse ?
Y'a quoi la bas ?
Y'a la mer.
Je parle pas de la dame.
Je parle de la mer derrière.
Parce qu'elle est surement une maman, je parle de la mer derrière, la "mer" l'eau.
CLÉMENT PU***N MAIS T'ES C** ...
Il est débile !
(Musique épique)
Bon, alors la grosse ironie du sort c'est qu'on est à la plage.
Et qu'il y'a que des Pokemon magnétiques.
Du coup on va essayer de tomber sur du "Voltorbe" et du "Magnéti".
Et on va essayer de les faire évoluer, c'est notre but aujourd'hui.
Je vais mettre un petit encens.
Pu***n de me***.
Bon, ça a raté.
C'est pas grave.
Tu vois là-bas y'a des arbres qui bougent.
Me demande pas "pourquoi y'a des arbres qui bougent alors que c'est du sable", j'en sais rien.
Ha ! Un "Krabby" !
Là on est d'accord.
Regarde un "Krabby" dans le sable.
Bon, il fait dix fois notre taille.
Mais y'a un "Krabby"
Hop-là !
Est-ce que je le capture ?
Fils de P**.
Fils de P** quand même.
Allez.
Première prise un "Krabby" 400, hein.
C'est pas des moindres.
HO !
Un "Voltorbe".
Il est là, il est sur le rebord.
Il essaie de m'impressioner en tournant sur lui même.
Le jeu a planté...
Tu sais, ils te disent "Fais attention regarde autour de toi"
Genre "attention y'a un Leviator qui va t'attaquer".
Mais on a tous envie qu'un Leviator nous attaque, en vrai.
Donc on a tous envie de pas faire attention autour de nous pour tomber sur un Leviator.
Tu comprends la logique Clément ?
Bonjour.
Une photo avec le meilleur dresseur, mais bien sûr, y'a pas de soucis.
C'est un "Mewtwo" par contre en échange.
Allez, merci le Ratatta.
Bonne journée.
Tu vois Clément ça, c'est quand les gens te reconnaissent pour ce que tu vaux et pas pour ce que... tu fais croire... que... tu... (Hésitation)
Je n'ai jamais été fort sur cette phrase.
HA !
Le Magnéti est là, attention !
Je crois qu'il est entre tes jambes, bouge pas.
C'est faux...
Il est à côté de toi, il vole !
Il est level trente-quatre mec, c'est un sketch !
Allez, on continue !
T'aime bien le sable dans les chaussures ?
Bah, moi aussi.
Ça tu vois, c'est un mec tu marché noir du Pokemon.
Y'a un marché noir qui s'est créé dans cette région.
Il vend tous les "Magnéti" et les "Vorltome" qu'il trouve.
Il les met dans des cartons et il les vend sur la plage.
Tu veux qu'on essaye d'en vendre un clandestinement juste pour te montrer ?
MAGNÉTI ! VORLTOME ! PAS CHER !
LEVEL 70 EN PLUS !
MAGNÉTI ! VORLTOME !
TU VEUX UN MAGNÉTI OU PAS ?
C'est quoi toi que t'as ?
Je peux voir ?
Voilà, MAGNÉTI ! VORLTOME !
C'est ça !
Tu veux un Vorltome ?
Un selfie...
Montre moi ce que tu as ?
Ça c'est fait.
MAGNÉTI ! VORLTOME !
C'est ça ! C'est ça !
C'est la technique...
Ha mais y'a une rivalité, elle est terrible cette rivalité je suis désolé.
Salut !
Ils essayent de m'amadouer pour voler mes Pokemon, il faut pas qu'on se laisse faire.
"Oui, ça va... oui !"
Fonce !
Bon, là-bas la légende dit qu'il y'a un Leviator.
On va essayer de le "Pécho".
Tu sais ce que c'est le problème sur cette plage Clément ?...
... Hormis le sol qui me crâme les pieds.
C'est que les gens on vite tendance à oublier qui est le meilleur dresseur.
Ils me respectent pas.
On va leur rappeler.
(Musique du générique de Pokemon)/(Musique joyeuse)
Je te présente mon "Lokhlass"... "Shiny".
(Bruit de vague)
Tu vois là le courant est pas bon, il va nous falloir un peu mieux que ça. (Essoufflé)
Il est level dix donc c'est une grosse M***E.
On va trouver autre chose.
(Musique d'action)
UN LÉVIATOR LA BAS !
Au P****N la y'a un truc a choper là Clément.
Y'a un truc à choper !
(Musique d'action)
(Cri)
P****N !
(Rire)
Mon gilet est mort.
Mon gilet de dresseur est mort !
Donc la je t'explique.
Tu te mets là et tu lance hyper loin la ligne.
Si tu la lance pas loin tu vas rien choper...
T'auras même pas un "Chenipan"
Et là tu lances, tu es prêt ?
Ok, donc la tu vois elle est dans l'eau.
Et à tout moment ça peut mordre.
Donc, on va attendre un peu.
Et puis je vais te tenir au courant.
Bon, ça devrait pas tarder à mordre là.
Ça fait quand même une heure et demi...
Tu filme pas ma raie du C**.
HO ! CLÉMENT !
(Cri)
Ça tire fort !
Y'A UN LÉVIATOR !
(Cri)
JE LE VOIS, IL EST ÉNORME !
CLÉMENT VAS-Y, AIDE MOI !
AIDE MOI !
HA ! LE LÉVIATOR !
HA, IL ME TIRE VERS LE FOND !
TA CRU C'ÉTAIT QUI LE MEILLEUR DRESSEUR ?!
FILS DE P**
JE L'AI !
C'EST QUOI CE BORDEL ?!
Clément, c'était Dory !
On a tué Dory... (Pleure)
On a tué Dory...
(Tousse)
J'AI BU LA TASSE !
DORY ?!
(Pleure)
DORY !!!
(Musique triste)
Clément, ça c'est des choses qui arrivent.
Tout bon dresseur voulant un Léviator vit des choses comme ça, très décevantes, très... des traumatismes.
Je suis traumatisé Clément.
C'est une déception, c'est un peu comme quand tu as un oeuf cinque kilomètres et que tu as un "Ratatta"...
C'est...
CLÉMENT ! CLÉMENT !
C'est quoi ça ?!
C'est un couple de dresseurs, je crois qu'ils voulaient avoir un Léviator.
Faut qu'on les aide Clément.
Faut qu'on les aide !
ON ARRIVE !
JE VOUS SAUVE CONTRE UNE "MASTER BALL" !
J'ARRIVE !
T'AS OUBLIE DE METTRE DE L'ESSENCE !
IL SERT À QUOI MON JET SKI MAINTENANT !?
ON ARRIVE !
ALLEZ-Y A-COTE D'EUX, ILS ONT BESOIN D'AIDE !
PLUS VITE !
P****N !
Attends, elle est seins nu la dresseuse ?
Elle est seins nu la dresseuse ?
Quoi, on va pas sauvé son mec.
J'arrive madame !
Venez tout va bien ce passer.
Paniquez pas !
Tu te calme !
Tu me laisse te sauver !
Laisse moi te sauver !
(Musique triste)
Clément, cette aventure à tes cotés était très sympathique mais je pense que le destin n'attend que moi et pas toi.
Ça veux rien dire mais tu vois ce que ça veux dire ?
Clément, il faut que j'y aille.
C'était un plaisir.
J'espère que t'auras appris plein de choses à mes cotés.
Et que tu captureras pleins de Pokemon rares.
Moi, j'ai eu ma dose.
Et y'a un Léviator qui m'attend la bas.
À bientôt Clément, je t'aime.
On se fait la bise quand même pour la fin ?
Nan, c'est une blague, c'est une blague, c'est une blague...
(Musique triste)
À bientôt Clément?
Je te souhaite de bonnes captures.
(Musique triste)
Un jour je serais le meilleur pêcheur, je capturerais pleins de truites...
(Musique outro)/(Musique joyeuse)